why not put a stake in the heart of evil
because that's what this really is this
is good and this is evil i know this
place has it in it to be better
i know it does
look at reality take your medicine
clean up the wound
and run
political alliances are shifting
there's a woman she was very prominent
in the the metoo movement rose mcgowan
she's a hollywood actress
she is i think traditionally on the left
i think she was pretty firmly on the
left and she saw behind the curt okay
she saw
what the power structures are really
like certainly within hollywood and more
broadly within the liberal establishment
of which hollywood
is a pretty significant part and so rose
mcgowan has been changing her
her relationship to politics
so much so i didn't think i would see
this day she has just come out and in
her state of california
is endorsing larry elder for governor
do you want a society that has gangrene
on its leg but puts on a fancy suit
and pretends it's not there while they
hobble in pain
or do you want to just stop
look at reality
take your medicine
clean up the wound
and run
run free
why not change
why not go big
why not put a stake in the heart of evil
because that's what this really is this
is good and this is evil i know this
place has it in it to be better
i know it does
i've met so many good people in this
country not the elites absolutely not
and then we have the jennifer siebel
newsomes of the world
why
why do you keep choosing that why do you
keep electing that
don't listen to their buzzwords cult
leaders
which is what these people are
i would know i grew up in one like i
said
they massage your mind
they keep you in fear
they keep you in doubt now notice she
mentioned
this newsome woman she's referring to
gavin newsom's wife and the story that
came out just came out on dave rubin's
show the mainstream media are totally
not touching the story
what rose is alleging and i have no
reason not to believe her and dave has
seen the emails and he's got the
receipts
is that
there was a pressure campaign to shut up
rose mcgowan six months before the
harvey weinstein story came out before
the metoo movement really
really broke
and gavin newsom's wife was one of the
people
according to rose
who was pressuring her and said hey
what do you need what do you need to go
away what how can we make you happy
now does that mean we're going to pay
you off does that mean we're going to
give you some position does that mean
we're going to put you in a movie what
does that mean
and
i have no reason not to believe her in
this specific case and we know that this
is a broader problem we know that the
swamp or the blob or the establishment
or whatever you want to call it
it looks out for itself and it's very
tied in together hollywood with the
press with the democratic party with the
entrenched interests
it's all
with big tech with the educational
establishment they're all really tied in
and they all really look after each
other and so when there's a real scandal
like the weinstein scandal don't as
people forget it now because weinstein
is a punchline
harvey weinstein was probably the most
powerful man in hollywood
they come out
and pull out all the stops to try to
protect one another
and so what rose mcgowan is seeing is i
think what a lot of
disaffected democrats and liberals are
seeing
which is they might say you know you
know michael
michael i don't agree with you on
everything and our views on the issues
might be
fairly different if we're talking about
i don't know what marriage or or
immigration or the america's role in the
world or what a citizen is we actually
might have different views on let's say
on every single political issue for that
matter
but
there are these matters of policy and
they're matters of issues and then there
are broader matters of the political
order the regime and what a lot of
people are seeing is regardless of what
i think on immigration abortion even
whatever
the ruling class is so sick and so
corrupt and so undeserving of its
authority that they're going to vote for
somebody else
they're just just to crack it up i think
a lot of people voted for trump for this
reason they said i don't care what he
thinks about war about immigration about
it i don't care he's not one of those
people and because those people are bad
they're really bad
so i'm going to vote for anyone else
that's an important thing
and so our democracy
gave us an attack on that ruling class
now the ruling class strikes back
i'm so glad that you liked that clip
that makes me feel good if you want to
leave me a comment that'd be great
you can also go to the michael knowles
show at apple podcast spotify stitcher
wherever you get your podcast just right
now pull out that phone pull it out let
me see i got i got mine here pull up
your podcast app type in the michael
knowles show subscribe
really appreciate it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]